hello everyone as the suggestion from a
subscriber I decided to add my twitch
username here right next to the board
you can see it here I with matter chess
it's not very creative I know but I
thought best keep it simple and like I
said feel free to follow that channel as
well as when I start my streams on
Twitch you can get notified and join all
the action this game here it's Louis
Paulson with the white pieces against
Paul Morphy the game is from the first
American chess congress in 1857 and as
many of you know morphe pretty much
destroyed the field at the tournament he
only lost one game in the finals against
Louie Paulson here but out of the 88
games they played the final result was
62 in more of his favor
so quite quite an amazing result to the
first prize for this tournament was $300
which morphe declined since you know he
was a wealthy guy he didn't really need
$300 but he showed everyone who's boss
so in this game Paulson has the white
pieces and he opens up with E 4 we have
E 5 buy more feet Knight to f3 knight c6
and Knight to c3 the three Knights
opening we have Knight to f6 the four
Knights game and Bishop to b5 the
Spanish variation of the four Knights
Bishop to c5 and Paulsen castles here we
have castles and now Paulsen plays
Knight captures on e5 going for
provoking Murphy to capture here so he
could put d4 and attack Murphy's bishop
and the night but after Knight to e5
Murphy ignores this and plays rook to e8
he doesn't care for material he's all
about development Knight captures on c6
d captures on c6 we have Bishop to c4 b5
now kicking the bishop further back
Bishop to e2 and now Murphy grabs the
pawn back Knight capture so we have rook
captures and Bishop to f3 attacking the
rook on e4 and before I forget here is a
photo of them playing these are all the
participants of the American chess
Congress I don't know if it's really all
of them but you know most of them
probably and here you can see morphe
playing Paulson I don't have I don't
really know if that's them but
it sure looks like it's them and I don't
know if morphine has like a tiny chair
or something or is Paulson a giant but
Paulson just looks like a monster
compared to Murphy here so I just wanted
to share that with you guys and hear
after Bishop to f3 attacking Murphy's
Rock Murphy retreats the rook to e6 we
have C 3 by Paulsen preparing d4 but
here morphe plays Queen to d3 he doesn't
allow Paulsen to put d4 b 4 by Paulsen
Bishop to b6 and now a 4b captures Queen
captures and Bishop to d7 by morphe
preparing to bring the other rock into
the game we are rock 88 and here is a is
a weird move by Paulsen here Queen to a6
immediately pretty much either forces
morphe to capture it or to move the
Queen to c2 or something but here he
plays rook to a2 and there's really no
good explanation to why he played rook
to a2i I did consider some things but as
his plan is to play Queen to a6 on the
next move I really see no point why rock
to a2 was played if any of you can find
any reasoning behind this move do share
in the comments so morph is simply
doubles up rook 88 and now Paulsen plays
Queen to a six but now Queen to a6 isn't
as potent as it was a move ago when the
before morphe doubled rook on the rooks
and e-file here morphe played well it's
it's probably not the best move in the
position but he played Queen captures on
f3 and here you don't really have any
choice but to capture the Queen
otherwise you're gonna be down a piece
so G captures on f3 pulse and accepts
the Queen and now rook captures on g6 as
you can to block this check you have to
move the King only move is king to h1
and here we have Bishop to h3 now
attacking the rook and this is that
critical moment of the game where your
opponent just sacrificed the Queen and
you have that one tiny opportunity where
you have a chance to actually defend
your position here Paulsen plays rook to
the
and this is the move that loses the game
instantly but instead of this rook to d1
there was a move Queen to d3 and now
after Bishop captures an f2 and this is
the best move as now Bishop to g2 is
threatening checkmate if you capture the
bishop on f2 you get rook to e1 check
but here actually Paulsen would have the
option of capturing Queen captures on g6
and after H characters on g6 now for
example rook to d1 and blacks position
is better his up upon and this Bishop is
still protecting the a7 pawn and the
game continues but after this Bishop to
h3 Paulsen plate rook to d1 and getting
the rock out of the way probably
preparing Queen to d3 and the next move
but now it's simply to wait here
Bishop to g2 was played this is what
Czech Paulsen has the more King to g1
now Bishop captures on f3 this is a
discovered check from the rook on g6 we
have King to f1 and now push up to g2
check King g1 Bishop to h3 check King to
h1 and here Murphy played Bishop
captures on f2 again threatening Bishop
to G - checkmate
and this Bishop to f2 is a good move
it's still still black is better and
black is winning this game but instead
of this Bishop captures on f2 in this
position morphe had a forced checkmate
in five moves and this is the position I
wanted you to see and try and find the
force checkmate in five it's not it's
not a completely obvious checkmate so
feel free to give it some time you know
pause the video and I really try to find
it as is it's a it's an excellent
checkmate and you will feel you know
amazing if you find it so do pause the
video so for those of you who managed to
find this congratulations it's really
really a while the series of moves and
for those of you who want to see this
brilliancy the idea is a Bishop to g2
check King TG want and now Bishop to e4
check King has to move the only square
available for the King is f1 and
after the king moves now comes the move
you had to see to actually find this
checkmate is Bishop to f5 now as you can
see the rook is control this rook is
controlling defiled this rook is
controlling the G file so the King can
go anywhere and the thread is Bishop to
h3 checkmate so there is only one way to
actually stop this this that's queen to
e2 but now it doesn't stop checkmate it
only prolongs it better to h3 check now
King has to move to the e-file King to
e1 and now rook to g1 and this is
checkmate as the Queen can't block well
even if the Queen could walk wouldn't
really matter but this is the checkmate
more famous than five I do hope some of
you found it as I really I really enjoy
it enjoyed this one but okay after King
- h1 Murphy played Bishop characters on
f2 and now Bishop to g2 is the threat of
checkmate Queen to f1 now Paulsen has to
give up the Queen if he wants to prolong
the game Bishop captures on f1 rod
captures on f1 and rook to e2 now
guarding his bishop and the king is
stuck in the corner here rook to a1 was
played rook to h6 by morphe d4 attacking
more fees rook on h6 and here morphe
simply played Bishop to e3 and in this
position loop Olson resigned at the game
if you capture the bishop then simply
rook captures on h2 King moves and the
other rope delivers checkmate on g2 on
the other hand after Bishop to e3
you do have a way of prolonging in this
game but it's you know it's just torture
for example rook to F do you have to
block blacks attack on the h2 pawn and
after rook captures an f2 now Bishop
characters here but now rook captures on
h2 with check King to g1 and now rook to
h1 check King moves and now rook
captures on a1 better captures G
captures and Europa rook this is the way
young Gustav son likes to play he's in
his end games he always says his
favorite and games are the ones where he
has a rook and his opponent doesn't but
Paulsen didn't go for this after rook
after Bishop to e3 he resigned the game
and morphe continued to win the first
American chess congress and then all the
other players in Europe so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I do
hope some of you managed to find that
very nice checkmate I would like to
thank Matt you Kirby for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon